demandant votre démission.
- Au Québec, on se souvient
du maire de Mascouche, Richard
Marcotte, et de la mauvaise
réputation dont il avait affublé
sa ville, qu'il a dirigée
de 1991 à 2012.
À l'époque, le député
de la région avait dénoncé
l'attribution de certains
contrats à des amis du maire.
L'élu du Parti québécois
avait subi les menaces
d'un entrepreneur qui a ensuite
été arrêté et emprisonné.
Aujourd'hui, le nouveau maire
de Mascouche, c'est lui :
Guillaume Tremblay. Il a été élu
en 2013 et réélu en 2017.
GUILLAUME TREMBLAY,
maire de Mascouche
- Lors de la première élection,
clairement, l'objectif
était justement, suite
à la commission Charbonneau,
de rentrer à la ville,
puis de faire un grand ménage.
(cliquetis d'appareils photo)
- De juin 2012 à l'automne 2014,
la commission présidée par
la juge France Charbonneau a
interrogé environ 300 témoins,
dont certains ont fortement
marqué les esprits.
- Je peux imaginer que
c'est lui, mais pas parce que
c'est reconnaissable, vraiment.
- C'est l'argent que vous venez
de mettre dans vos bas
avec M. Zambito, c'est exact?
- Oui.
- 3 % des contrats que
allait au parti politique
du maire Tremblay.
- Aucuns frais?
- Un chum, c'est un chum!
Me DENIS GALLANT, ancien procur.
adj. en chef comm. Charbonneau
- Notre mandat, nous autres,
c'était de démontrer
des stratagèmes. Puis, au niveau
municipal, je pense que cette
démonstration-là, on l'a faite.
Il y a du monde qui m'écrivait
des courriels "live",
j'interrogeais, là, puis
qui me disaient : "Vous devriez
poser cette question-là".
Il finissait par son nom
par "ingénieur", là.
Fait que j'ai dit :
"On va l'essayer!"
Cet argent comptant là
servait à quoi?
- Au financement
des partis politiques.
- Je n'ai jamais fait
d'aveuglement volontaire.
Je veux que ça soit très clair.
- Êtes-vous naïf?
- Je ne suis pas naïf.
- Ça veut pas dire parce qu'on a
un nom italien qu'on fait partie
du crime organisé, hein?
SUZANNE COUPAL,
juge à la retraite
- Ce que la commission
Charbonneau a fait, elle a pris
certains pans de l'enquête
policière qui était commencée,
qui marchait, et elle s'en est
servi pour dire : voici la
corruption qu'il y a à Laval.
Par la suite, les procès
à Laval, dont, entre autres, du
maire Vaillancourt à l'époque,
ont continué et il a été
condamné, de même que
plusieurs de ses acolytes.
A ce niveau-là, la commission
Charbonneau n'a pas apporté
quelque chose de neuf
pour les tribunaux.
- On contribue exclusivement
pour la démocratie...
- Non!
- ... ou on contribue aussi
pour tisser des liens?
- Bien, c'est sûr que ça permet
de tisser des liens. Oui, oui.
C'est...
- Le pouvoir discrétionnaire,
pour moi, c'est un pouvoir qui
permet de faire contrepoids
au pouvoir des fonctionnaires.
- Autre critique : après que la
démonstration des stratagèmes
illégaux de financement
politique au Parti libéral
du Québec ait été clairement
établie, pourquoi le premier
ministre Jean Charest n'a-t-il
pas été appelé à témoigner?
Une question qui reste sans
réponse, 10 ans plus tard.
- On a compris qu'il y en avait
des relations, certainement dans
les villes, en tout cas,
avec les élus des villes et
l'attribution des contrats.
Au provincial, on peut penser
que c'est arrivé, quoique
la machine du gouvernement
provincial est plus lourde
pour l'attribution des contrats.
Mais est-ce que vraiment,
on a laissé échapper les gros
poissons? En fait, c'est encore
à voir, ce qui va se passer
avec ça.
- L'enquête policière Machurer
est toujours en cours
à ce sujet.
- Vous n'avez pas à décider
de la pertinence des questions.
- On a beaucoup dit que cette
commission a coûté très cher.
- Oui, c'est énorme, là,
50 millions, on s'entend. C'est
pas rien. Mais l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté la Loi
sur la récupération des sommes
qui auraient été détournées,
a modifié des lois et a créé
un programme de remboursement
volontaire. Aux dernières
nouvelles, on aurait récupéré
plus de 100 millions.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ici, on est au coin de Charny
et Coursol; on parle de travaux
d'excavation majeurs. Donc, on
parle de changement des tuyaux,
des services, mais aussi
l'asphaltage, les bordures de
ciment. Donc, pour vous donner
un exemple concret, il y a eu
10 soumissionnaires : entre
2,25 millions arrondi, là,
à 3,5 millions. Donc, on parle
de 800 000 de différence
entre le plus bas et le
plus haut soumissionnaire.
- Avec les économies réalisées
au fil du temps, la Ville
de Mascouche a pu créer son
propre service d'ingénierie.
C'est l'une des retombées
concrètes de la commission
Charbonneau : la réduction
du coût des travaux publics et
l'assainissement des relations
entre élus et entrepreneurs.
- Clairement, puis ça, c'est
avantageux pour l'ensemble
des citoyens parce que ça nous
permet de faire plus de travaux
dans la Ville de Mascouche